Hi and welcome back to the Variational Quantum Eigensolver course series.
My name is Victoria Lipinska and in this video we will dive into how to represent
a given VQE problem in a way that the quantum computer understands.
Typically, a quantum chemistry problem is expressed in terms of energies
of the system.
We refer to the operator, which describes these energies as the Hamiltonian.
First, we need to quantize it.
That is express it in the language of quantum chemistry,
which is formally called second quantization.
If the Hamiltonian describes fermion interactions, for example,
energy of electrons in spin orbitals, we refer to this
as fermionic Hamiltonian, and it will be our starting point today.
Qubits, however, have their own language.
The operators in the qubit world are described by the Pauli operators.
So our focus here is to express the fermionic operators
in terms of qubit operators.
There is a simple one-to-one correspondence between
the zero and one states for fermions and qubits.
So the mapping between the states is also straightforward.
However, the mapping of the operators is slightly more complex.
But fermionic Hamiltonians are expressed with creation and
annihilation operators.
So our job is to make it easier for a quantum computer to understand
the Hamiltonian.
We will use mathematical tools to map a fermionic Hamiltonian
into a qubit Hamiltonian with gates.
So in other words, we will be translating between
the quantum chemistry language and quantum computing language.
Imagine two chains, one with fermions,
so quantum chemistry language.
And one with qubits, so quantum computing language.
At the first glance, the mapping seems straightforward, right?
In both cases, we see systems with two levels.
For fermions, we have either one fermion in the state
or no fermion at all.
And for qubits, we have either state 0 or state 1.
However, it's more nuanced than that.
The difference between a chain of qubits and a chain of fermions
is something very fundamental in physics: what we call exchange symmetry.
Two fermions can never occupy the same state.
However, for a chain of qubits, this is completely different.
Two qubits can both be in the same state,
as a qubit is not a fermion.
We must now find a way to translate between the two chains.
already in 1928, two researchers, Jordan and Wigner,
showed that fermionic operators for the whole chain
can be represented exactly in terms of qubit operators.
This is the most straightforward mapping for a quantum computer.
For example, one can use that to map an occupation
of an orbital to the spin of one qubit.
Practically, this mapping for a Hamiltonian results results in a weighted sum of Pauli operators.
This is a very important fact, which I'd like you to keep in mind,
and we will come back to this in the next module where we will talk
about how variational circuits are executed on the quantum computer.
The above mapping means that if we had, for example,
14 fermionic operators, we will map the problem onto 14 qubits.
Luckily, there exist clever ways to reduce the numbers of qubits
and use less quantum resources to get a better performance from a quantum computer.
Typically, in a molecular system, we will know
some physical symmetries of the Hamiltonian,
for instance, the total number of electrons is fixed.
This information can be used to reduce the size of the problem
without losing any relevant information.
We call this technique the active space reduction.
This allows for the reduction of number of resources, namely, number of qubits,
before the qubit mapping like Jordan-Wigner transformation.
This step calculates an effective Hamiltonian
and allows us to use less qubits as a result.
For our example with 14 orbitals,
this technique reduces the number of qubits to just six.
We can now go even further with these reductions.
We can use different mappings,
which are a little bit more elaborate than Jordan-Wigner.
The most common example is the parity mapping.
Parity mapping doesn't map occupation of the orbitals on the qubits,
but rather the parity of orbitals onto single qubits.
We will not go into the mathematical details here,
but what's important to know is that this mapping contains additional
redundancies which can be utilized to remove two more qubits.
Therefore, our example with 14 orbitals, reduces from 14 qubits
to 6 qubits with active space reduction and then to 4 qubits
with the two qubit reduction in the parity mapping.
Let us briefly mention one more transformation.
Another commonly used mapping between the fermionic
and qubit representation is the Bravyi-Kitaev transformation.
The Bravyi-Kitaev transformation uses qubits to encode the information
about both the occupation number and the parity of the quantum state.
The Bravyi-Kitaev transformation combines occupation number and parity information
for a molecular orbital basis of size N,
there are again N and qubits used.
However, the information stored within each qubit
now varies depending on which qubit it is.
That is when the index of the qubit is even,
its stores the occupation number of the corresponding
orbital number as in the Jordan-Wigner mapping.
When the qubit index is odd, the qubit stores a parity of a particular
set of occupation numbers. Bravyi-Kitaev transformation is the most efficient
when the number of qubits approaches the power of two.
The Bravyi-Kitaev mapping combines the advantages from the Jordan-Wigner
and the parity transformations.
It reduces the number of qubits that each Hamiltonian term acts on,
It's important for quantum simulation as terms
acting on the large number of qubits in the Hamiltonian
require longer circuits for their simulation.
This means that the circuit depth
is reduced with the Bravyi-Kitaev transformation and in general
we can obtain better results with hardware.
This is an improvement over the Jordan-Wigner transformation
which results in order of N qubit Hamiltonian.
So, in this video we explored methods to map
a fermionic Hamiltonian onto a qubit Hamiltonian.
In the next one we'll see how to best select the state
and a variational form or a circuit.
We'll see you there.